[Music]
That's strange, so I'll charge you the taste first.
The beauty of the flow of
the seasons.
[Music]
My name is Toshio Fukushima. I am the 4th generation owner of this Fukushima shop.
I am Shintaro Fukushima. I am the 6th generation owner
.  It is a traditional sweet from ancient times
Ha
means Japan.
Sweets means sweets. Japanese
sweets are moderately sweet.
The deliciousness of white bean paste
This is what I put in.
We make about 200 types of sweets
in a year.The
types change with
the seasons.
There is also a daffodil flower or a camellia
wabisuke.
I use what I copied.Some items are made using wooden molds that have been handed down from
generation to generation.
I think that this is a big reason why my child developed in Japanese culture.We
have been able to continue this work for many years and have a history of nearly 170 years.This is a
great pride for us.
I am aiming for this